news from the germany team just moments
before kickoff they've announced that
alex popp is out with a muscular injury
she's the top scorer for the team six
goals joint with england's beth mead and
she's also provided a number of assists
that is a significant loss for germany a
significant piece of their attacking
play is now out we've been talking about
how they're going to control pot how
they're going to stop and jumping in the
air all day long what a boost for the
england team yeah and she's the captain
as well hoot is taken over as captain
they're saying leah sherlo is taking
pop's place in the team so
also for england their game plan would
have been set up how to counteract the
threat of pop they're going to have to
quickly perhaps adjust how they're
setting up to tackle this
new look germany but we don't want to
jinx things down to take things for
granted but they might be quietly
pleased the fact pop won't be in the
starting lineup no absolutely i mean
absolutely we have just about been
talking about her and concentrating on
her and talking about no other german
player all afternoon um
wondering what the germans are thinking
now that they they won't be able to play
her does it say that she's out
completely or she might be on the bench
i guess we don't
we don't know that yet yeah we're just
picking up it's actually the tweet from
the german federation the dfb who said
this and
let's just think about pop as well the
fact she missed euro 2013 and 17 through
injury this was a euros debut at 31
so close to potentially be able to lead
them to glory injury heartache again for
pop yeah she was desperate wasn't she to
to win a european title and she's one of
one of the few german german players
who's he's not won one because they've
they've won this title eight times going
for a ninth this was the dream final the
one they all wanted and she is out alex
popp the star german player is out with
a muscle problem we are waiting for the
flypass
which is going to happen any second now
uh speaking about the flypass flight
lieutenant lauren it's an all-female raf
crew said i'm proud to be piloting the
lead aircraft for the flypast over
wembley i flow missions all over the
world with the raf but this will be one
of the most memorable it's been
inspiring to watch the lionesses
progress and i will be loudly cheering
them on as soon as i land back at raf
bryce norton
incredible scenes on wembley way
completely empty now obviously everyone
has come down here has got a ticket and
they're in there and waiting for this
incredible occasion to begin
what do you think what do you think
serena wiegmann will have said to those
players earlier in the tournament she
said play for the little girl who wants
to be in your shoes do you think she
might say play for yourself because you
were a little girl
who never got to play in a girls team
we should be wanting them players to
seize the occasion as we have the
players flying right overhead beyond
there they fly past over wembley
and the players will be hearing that the
raw the energy and i think with serena
vegas key message will have been seized
this moment for the impact it could have
not only on these players the team and
the country for girls who dream of
playing football and potentially the
players who are about to kick off their
lives can be defined by what happens in
wembley